[Music]
by all accounts this is a moment that
almost never came to be Young School
boys connecting with Afghanistan's
ancient history a Crossroads of Empires
and religions stretching back thousands
of years
the museum they're standing in was
nearly burnt to the ground during the
Civil War of the 90s then it was
ransacked Smugglers looted 70 percent of
its collection
flooding the global Black Market with
tens of thousands of ancient pieces of
Persian Buddhist and Islamic dynasties
smuggling of artifacts dates back a long
time in Afghanistan but during the wars
Not only was this Museum affected but
also our provincial museums that held
some of the most valuable artifacts and
all of our historic sites they all fell
victim to theft and destruction
Decades of conflict have devastated
Afghanistan criminals and traffickers
took advantage of the instability and
stripped its archaeological sites nearly
bare some destroyed completely like the
Buddhas of bamian
1500 year old colossal statues famously
blown up by the Taliban in 2001.
if you think of Afghanistan's history as
a book every page that goes missing a
piece of History also goes missing the
smuggling of artifacts means our culture
suffers that entire movements are
forgotten so it's better that we as an
entire nation put in an effort to
protect our artifacts so that our
history isn't incorrect or incomplete
taliban's return to power in 2021 there
was worry about further looting or
destruction but the group vowed to
protect Afghanistan's cultural heritage
these are National values and it is our
responsibility to protect them and the
ministry of culture has this special
responsibility at all customs and
airports we have security teams to
prevent smuggling of artifacts last year
we stopped more than a thousand
historical artifacts that were being
smuggled we arrested them brought them
to court and handed over the artifacts
to the National Museum
once at the Moon
he knew their work to carefully Preserve
Afghan times rebuilding it Shard by
Shard and though they don't have the
funding or the proper facilities to work
to the standard they like they persevere
cabell's museum is a place of resilience
doing what it can to hold up and connect
generations of Afghans with the history
of where they came from Alexandra Byers
Al Jazeera
let's get all the sport now and